you
[Music]
my name's Nick crane and I work for a UK
company called elucidate er we do
software engineering that's rooted in
data science that means things like
analytically focused software products
decision engines and more generally
robust and scalable data processing
solutions I've been using our for about
eight years on and off now but I've been
using it's part of my full-time job for
about three years so still kind of new
to a lot of this the project that I'm
going to be talking to you about today
is one that I feel genuinely privileged
to be part of firstly because I'm
getting to see shiny push to a point
that I would have never thought possible
a couple of years ago but also because
it's got a real human impact I find as
somebody that works in data it's quite
common to end up on projects where
that's kind of quite far abstracted for
me where in this project that's less so
so I'm gonna start by giving you a bit
of background about the project and I'm
gonna talk about the shiny app that we
built to support it and I'm gonna finish
off by just going through some of the
lessons we learned when we were scaling
up the app but actually before I get
started and can I just get a show of
hands who here has heard of the hundred
thousand genome project just pop your
hand up okay Wow so a lot more of you
than I thought actually and but some of
you haven't oh gosh okay that's a popped
up there never mind okay so some of you
haven't heard of the project so in that
case I'm gonna start by just giving you
a bit of context by telling you about
one of the participants in the project
ok so this is K this is Simon and the
one in the middle is their daughter
could Jessica Jessica is 4 years old
when she was born everything seemed to
be going well until Jessica was around
thirteen months of age and at that point
Kate and Simon notices she wasn't moving
around as much as other children her age
and unfortunately she also began having
seizures so obviously they were very
worried and wanted to know what was
going on it turned out that Jessica had
a condition called book1 deficiency
syndrome and what that means is her
brain isn't getting enough glucose or
energy now this is a rare disease and it
can be managed by a special diet but the
problem with that is to manage it you
have to have the diagnosis and in
patients like this with rare diseases it
takes on average three incorrect
diagnoses and four years to get to that
final diagnosis so obviously that's a
very stressful time during that process
and actually patients end up on this
journey that's referred to in the
medical literature as a diagnostic
Odyssey which means these kind of
endless hospital appointments trying to
figure out what is going on and this was
no different for Jessica so she went for
eg scans MRIs lumbar punctures and still
doctors were no closer to having
diagnosis
luckily viasport Network and Jessica's
family were put in touch with a hundred
thousand genome project and fire a blood
sample from each of them Jessica and her
parents had their genome sequence and
mapped and they're able to get a
diagnosis so this is one of the uses for
the hundred thousand genome project
getting genomes mapped from patients
with rare diseases and getting that
diagnosis a lot quicker than otherwise
would have happens another use for the
project is a mapping genomes and tissue
from tumor tissue and when cancer
patients to figure out what treatment
will respond best to so the hundred
thousand genome project and was set up
by the UK government with the aim of
sequencing a hundred thousand genomes
from patients with either rare diseases
or cancer and they actually mapped that
goal last month in December 2018 and the
results are still been analyzed from
that now so just for a little bit of
detail about the science behind it I
won't spend too long on this and
scientists have been able to sequence
DNA since the 1970s but in the past it
was only 5% of that information that was
actually used and 95% of it was
discarded the first full human genome
was sequence in 2003 it took over ten
years and two billion dollars to get to
that point but now a full human genome
can be sequenced in under a day and for
less than a thousand dollars and so yeah
as I said a 100 thousand genome project
set up by the UK government to sequence
100,000 genomes with patients with rare
diseases and cancer
now following on from this project is
the rollout of the national genomics
medicine service and this is the bit
that's really exciting stuff this is
groundbreaking the NHS the National
Health Service in the UK is going to be
the first public healthcare system to
offer genomic testing as part of its
routine health care this is like really
exciting to be involved in this but it's
not just the actual genomic data that's
important here there's actually a
massive series of steps to get from that
initial blood sample
the final clinical report the DNA is
extracted it's since one organization to
another word to another and so on
there's people with different jobs we've
got people so bioinformaticians we've
got people in the lab and it's a very
complex process using data of different
types and what is needed here is some
way of letting people in this process
interact with the surrounding metadata
but not have to go anywhere near this
level of complexity so that's where
shiny comes in
so we built a shiny app called the mi
portal or management information portal
that allows people at all different
stages of the data pipeline to interact
with the metadata surrounding it and get
their job done okay so when I say this
is a shiny hat this is probably the
biggest shiny app I've ever worked on
and it's more like a mega app made up of
a series of suburbs now we used more
different art packages and I've got time
to know him but in brief we had a set of
core packages so things like shiny
attire verse and packages for working
with all the databases and api's that
are involved in the process we use a lot
of packages to customize the look and
feel but actually probably one of the
most important category packages were
HTML widgets and actually as a shiny
developer hate summer widgets are
probably my favorite and least favorite
thing in some ways just because I can
spend ages working on some really
complex feature really pushing my art
skills to limit and trick HTML widget on
the top of that and when I talk to
clients about it it's always the HTML
widget they're impressed by but joking
aside HTML widgets are a really great
insert of packages if you've not heard
of them they basically allow you to
import these kind of complex JavaScript
libraries into your shiny app and allow
this really rich interactive
functionality so I think I've already
covered most of this but just to
reiterate the main priorities around
designing this app which create an app
that could be used by people in
different stages of the prose project
each dashboard or sub app needed to
answer either one question or a sort
small subset of questions well and
another priority would fail to iterate
quickly so as I said this is the first
time this has been done and it's one of
these projects where it really wasn't a
we weren't able to get a really clear
idea of what would be needed so this
project can open the app around it
evolved as the project went on
and that's part of the reason we use
SHINee actually SHINee has capability
for rapid prototyping made it perfect to
use in this project okay so what I'm
gonna do now is I'm gonna run through a
couple of examples of people who might
be using this app and and the kind of
questions to be asking and just show you
how that would actually look in the app
so firstly I could be a program manager
a genomics England I might want to know
how close we are to the hundred thousand
genomes targets let's pretend for a bit
that they've not got there yet and I one
might want to know how many of these
samples come from patients with either
cancer or rare diseases there are a lot
of different metrics actually that can
be looked at in the process so just how
do they break down by the different
stages and also if there's any samples
getting stuck in the case pipeline where
are they getting stuck how did this vary
by clinic so then I can hopefully do
something about that okay so we've got a
version of the app here that's been
loaded up with some dummy data so I'm
just gonna open up the ops and
management information dashboard so we
get a few high level metrics again we've
added in some features like tool tips
just to get the specific definition of
that metric because he actually is quite
important
we've got a couple of plots they're
using plotly actually HTML widget so we
can just hover over and drill down and
get a little bit more information and
again just another plot little plot just
to show the overall values but actually
if we go into the main dashboard now we
can get much more detailed information
okay so we've got a map tricked by
different stage the process and again
we've included just tool tips just to
get a bit of extra kind of information
there we've intentionally got some
really simple plots on the right because
for more detail we want to go into the
case pipeline status so here we've used
a HTML widget called sunburst R which is
actually really great for tracking
sequences of events so if I select a
couple of clinics
okay and I'll just give that a moment to
load and now if I start with the mouse
going from the inside of the chart
outwards and each kind of ringg going
out represents where in the pipeline
things are so I might keep going out to
see how many samples have got to that
point and I can hover over a different
thing to say okay lots of things on hold
at that point so I might want to go and
investigate that so we that that's live
and in production at the moment and
we've got good feedback on people being
able to get just a really quick
of what's going on there so another
years of the app then might be the
sample seem in the lab so so a very
different job to the previous example
this is the person that's actually
working with the DNA day to themselves
so if they've got to say a problem with
the DNA sample they need to be able to
provide the ups that people downstream
of them know that that shoe exists they
might want to know what are the other
related samples in the case hierarchy so
when I say case hierarchy when I was
talking about Jessica and a woman dead
before they're all part of the same case
hierarchy and I might just want to see
if the sample has been flood before so
has somebody else or already identified
this particular issue so again we've
loaded this up with dummy data this is
an actual data so I'll open up
processing flag tool and search for a
particular case so that goes to our
database and we get the information for
the case so again we've got another HTML
widget here called viz network so we can
see all the different entities within
that particular case once I click on
that that villain loads up some
information about that so we can see the
history for that particular and that
sample we've got some metadata there
about the sample and then I can use the
kind of update tool to just type in some
information about what's gone wrong and
then this will send that after or API
and then should hopefully update the
flag history so yeah and then that's
that updated that there and we've used a
few of the things just around the UI so
if somebody types in something without
actually specifying a reason we just get
this nice modal dialogs helpfully guide
these and what they're supposed to be
doing so that's just another kind of
aspect of the app and that's been rolled
out that's deployed that's live at the
moment and so that one's successfully so
the next step then is to take the best
bits of that app and a few of the bits
for the rollout of the National genomics
medicine service however the things are
a little bit different this time
so as this has been rolled out across
the entire country the new version of
the app needs to be able to support
hundreds if not thousands of concurrent
users so we really needed to scale it up
there now I did originally intend to
show you the final kind of version of
the app but as with any live project
we're not quite at that point yet but
what is more interesting and what I can
share with you are the main things that
we actually learn in the process of
scaling it
I think that would actually be much more
kind of interesting to go into okay so
firstly then how did we scale Yap so we
did partially scale the up horizontally
so the apps deployed in docker
containers and we could just keep adding
more containers and have one user per
app but we didn't want to do just that
we wanted each individual instance of
the app to be able to support multiple
users so we can take advantage of
certain features like caching so we
needed to scale vertically as well and
to do this part of the solution was to
use the future and promises package
packages and make some of the app
asynchronous so users wouldn't be
blocking up each of the sessions now in
order to see which bits we needed to
speed up we made some realistic user
Pat's and map those out
obviously the limitation here is that
we've got people using the app for
different things but in our initial test
we just decided to pick something that
was quite database and API intensive and
use a lot of complex shiny code just to
kind of really see where our bottlenecks
are likely to lie and we use proffers
and shiny load tests to have a look at
it so a few things that we found there
there's a really great talk I think it
might be lust for me at last year's
conference by Joe Cheng and he talks
about finding watermelons not
blueberries in other words find the big
kind of slow bits to optimize first so
we were quite happy to see that a lot of
the things that we kind of expected so
database calls and API calls they were
the main things that were slowing us
down although there was a little bit we
had to focus on around the shiny code
first as well which I'll come back to in
a moment we also use shiny load tests to
see how the app performed with different
number of people using at the same time
and actually one of the biggest insights
we took from that so with the graph on
the Left we can see that creating the
asynchronous version of the app can have
reduced the amount of variation the
graph on the right it looks like there's
not much difference but actually what's
happened is making the app asynchronous
has reduced the outliers m2 the really
longer sessions and actually what we
realized is it's not just about
optimizing to reduce latency it's also
about optimizing to have really
consistent experiences between different
people there's a lot of stuff out there
about the kind of the 99 percentile
around optimization and so we realized
consistency was a really important thing
for us so I'm gonna finish off just with
the key
kind of lessons we learn here so kind of
just as joe said before i think it's
really easy to get hung up on
conversations around the scaling
focusing on let's make everything
asynchronous but what we actually found
that was really important to try to
optimize our shiny code first so I know
that kind of as a new as shiny developer
I did fall into the trap of certain
things like filling my code with lots of
complicated render you eyes and we have
to kind of get rid of kind of anything
that was like that there is also a quite
common shiny ANSI pattern which is
referred to as coding things
imperatively so it's using a lot of kind
of observers and reactive values
together where it's not necessarily
appropriate and it's not really taking
advantage of the benefits of reactive
programming so we really had to kind of
make sure that our code followed that
pattern and conform to best practices
and that was really key to what we were
doing another thing as well as it was
the database and API calls and that were
kind of the main slow things we found it
was really important to take advantage
of the advanced functionality of sequel
so I think as a data scientist that
doesn't do much sequel sometimes it can
be easy to fall into the trap of
thinking it's all you know create real
place update delete enjoins but actually
using a bit of that wider functionality
meant we were able to move more of our
processing on to the database we used a
lot of database functions as well just
because we didn't want to be
constructing these kind of complex
database calls in art it's fine to do
that but it was just nice for us to
conceptually have that separation of the
different parts of the app and and also
just that writing efficient sequel is
pretty important so we worked really
closely with our engineering team around
this side of things a few other little
peep it some pieces we did so we did a
bit around optimizing data loading so on
some of these sub apps and there were
certain user paths sort of fairly
predictable so a user it's going to load
up a certain screen they're going to
look at the metrics there and then
they're going to go on to another screen
so in that case we decided if that's
pretty much what they're going to do all
the time
we're going to actually load the data
that they need from the database ahead
of time so then they only need to
connect to the shiny session rather than
you know the session and then the
database and that helped and finally
just going back to what I was saying
before about HTML widgets they're
absolutely fantastic for interacting
with data I think that when I was
training shiny apps earlier
career there was a lot of focus maybe on
click on different inputs and then that
goes back to the shiny session but
actually you can get a lot of the
richness on what people are looking at
and what people are drilling down with
HTML widgets and we found those were
crucial to our design so um this has
been an absolutely fantastic project to
work on and it's been really interesting
just figuring out how to scale up the
app and I just got to come on indulge
myself with like something I've noticed
actually in a couple of years of working
with shiny as a consultant and a shiny
developer it seems that it's changed a
bit how shiny is being used so when I
first saw it I think I saw a lot of
organizations using shiny for these
really inward faces think inward facing
apps are sharing data within their
organization and it's really exciting to
be working with shiny at the moment
where you can see all these kind of
things being scaled up making it really
production capable like Joe was talking
about earlier today okay so thank you
all for coming along and thanks to the
rest of my team as well
[Applause]
great we have time for a couple of
questions who's got a question
we go
I apologize for a seminar question okay
as you're removing logic out into more
sequel things to speed it up how did you
handle testing that than a sequel
infrastructure and a lot of our testing
is done manually so we have a testing
team so we didn't need to automate that
so we kind of got around that issue
other questions
I'm interested to know if as you rolled
it out if you begun to have real use
have you had any user level performance
um not yet no we're still kind of in the
process of finishing off for scaling up
but hopefully we will and we're going to
hopefully continue the development
process in respondents to exactly what
they're saying corollary to that on the
database side do you have challenges or
concerns about being sure that the
infrastructure supporting the database
remains responsive and there's not on my
side of things but then it's more the
engineering team that dealing with that
so I'm not sure sorry okay
Hynek thank you how did you manage
people getting back to you I'm telling
you there's a bug here I think there's
an issue here I mean there's too many
people working with the app how did you
manage that sorry can you just repeat
the question I did um
I mean how did you manage people getting
back to you with the Box like I don't
know how to explain it like telling you
I think there's an issue here in this
part of the code did the email do that
oh I say so and in terms of the actual
end Jesus then and that's just managed
yep I'd kind of an email process I mean
in terms of the test scene we have kind
of internal kind of software that we use
to manage bugs like JIRA and things like
that
[Music]